Carrie Underwood getting emotional the
country superstar revealing her
heartbreaking struggles with fertility
we got pregnant
early 2017 and didn't work out got
pregnant again in the spring and it
didn't work out got pregnant again early
2018 didn't work out so at that point it
was just kind of like okay like Wilder
thro I keep getting pregnant if I can't
have a kid the emotions still very much
raw as Carrie reveals she suffered three
devastating miscarriages in less than
two years leading up to last month's
pregnancy announcement a source tells ET
quote she has an incredibly supportive
family and leaned on them and her
closest friends to get through it all
have these horrible things going on in
my life and then I have to go smile and
like do some interviews really do a
photo shoot or something you know I saw
firsthand just how much of a
professional Carrie remained during that
heartbreaking time 2017 you're gonna
relax a little bit and take a little
time off enjoyed yeah I mean always
tough to do right now I'm kind of in the
in the process of remembering what it's
like to be human
but this face on for the world and
sometimes you dis can't carry told CBS
Sunday morning she channeled that pain
into the title track of her new album
cry pretty
my son Isaiah is the sweetest thing and
he's the best thing in the world it
sucked
so much but things are looking better
[Music]